all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 4600 block of east
charleston
which occurred in an apartment complex
directly behind me the details that i
have right now are very preliminary
but at around 8 30 tonight we responded
on a report of a female
an 18 year old female who had been shot
that female was transported to umc
trauma where she was pronounced deceased
what we have learned is that a group of
juveniles
and young adults were hanging out in a
vehicle parked in the parking lot
the group of them were in the car
listening to music
and at some point someone was armed with
a handgun
in the back seat that person armed with
the handgun fired around
in the vehicle striking the victim and
killing her
all the occupants in the back seat then
fled the scene and at this point that's
who we are looking for is the people who
are in the back seat we believe we are
there's still three people outstanding
one female
and two males who are in the backseat of
the vehicle we're still in the process
of trying to identify them
and locate them at this time so with
that i will take a couple questions but
i urge anybody who has any information
to please reach out to crime stoppers
you can do it anonymously or you can
also reach out to homicide at lvmpd.com
so we know the males are both uh black
males
in their late or late teens potentially
juveniles we also know there's a female
who's a black female
who we believe is 18 to 19 years of age
any idea if the gunshot was accidental
right now we don't know what led up to
the shooting as far as if it's
accidental or intentional we're still
looking in
to both possibilities not rolling either
out
how many people were in the vehicle
there was a total of
six people who were inside the car when
the shooting occurred
now we have there are three people that
we are speaking with
nobody has there's nobody in being
detained right now as a suspect
that is correct
are you having uh witnesses they're
being helpful any witnesses
uh neighbors yeah right now all the
witnesses that are on scene are being
cooperative with investigators and
that's where we're at at this point
we're still trying to piece everything
together
i don't know the name of the complex
it's the 4600 block of east charleston
and um when this occurred was the victim
walking towards the car they were i'm
sorry not to cut you off they were all
sitting inside the vehicle when it
occurred oh even the victim
yes everybody was sitting inside the car
oh okay
do you know how many this makes this
year it's been a busy year for you guys
so far
i don't know this uh number it's been at
this point
and what does it do what does it do to
restart when you have so many homicides
and it's such a short time
does that stretch you guys in a little
bit does it i mean what happens
in in your shop we're fully equipped to
investigate any amount of homicides that
we have it's not uh there has not been
a large amount of homicides that we've
had at this point so all right thank you
guys
as of this point regarding the
relationship between the victim and the
suspect
we don't know we believe they are
acquaintances from when they were in
school together but that's all we know